[Music]
welcome back to another spectacular
episode of the careful boys careful
we're talking about inspired by some of
Steve's recent talks about Kevin Hart
but also submitted by our very very dear
Discord
member AG I think a g baby o want to
chat with us you can join the patreon
which takes you directly to Discord okay
so she said and asked who is your
favorite celebrity you've ever met when
and where were you there's so many it's
going to be how long do we have to do
this one stupid you can go last to make
sure you have the least amount of time
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think someone that
I'm kind of like still to this day in in
disbelief would be uh Dante BOS he's the
best cuz like Hook was my childhood bro
like on that's a great one is not only
like hands down one of the movies that
me and my friends pretend to be we were
lost boys we would watch it over and
over and then like Rufio was such a dick
and you're just like but then later
you're like oh I feel bad for you I know
why you're a dick you know pan abandoned
your ass but he also had a sword he also
had the sword which everyone else didn't
but that's why I got mered though he was
so cool and then the Avatar you know the
the air bender you know he was the voice
of Zuko all that and when I was out like
playing poker one day and I saw him at a
casino and then my friend was just like
go say hi to him he's probably cool and
then I did and he was cool we all played
poker he actually seen JK before and I
think from that point on it was like so
cool to like not only be friends with
your Idol but work with your idol yeah
that is really good answer dude that's a
[__] sick ass he's also like somebody
that like I felt like I owed you know
because cuz you're Filipino cuz I'm but
then in other ways too like before I
even really met him um he had uh so I
got I I started working for uh Olympic
ice skaters doing their music for like
um Olympics and stuff that happened
because of Dante BOS what yeah because
they were wondering who to get for music
and they described this like type of
style they wanted and then he knew that
I was doing the Quest Crew mixes for our
shows and suggested me and without even
really knowing him yet and that's how I
know him well he put me in his movie he
put me on for no reason he didn't do
[__] for
me you don't talk to him on a regular
yes I do yet I like that here in
there I'm the one that brings them what
would you like what would you like Dante
to do for you put me in his movie or
something just anything I could just
like clean a car in the
background that's didn't you have to
like go somewhere for that too you have
to like travel yeah he flew me out to
NorCal I was in his City one of his
cities that he grew up in for fabulous
Filipinos yeah F and I played uh
Infamous Vietnamese gangster siit that
was so surprising cuz I didn't know you
were in it and I was watching it on
South by Southwest streaming yeah and I
was like I I I went to the back to get
something and I heard your [__] voice
and I went who changed the [__]
Channel I think that's that's what and
then I met all of his brothers they're
[__] cool I envy their relationship
cuz like they're literally like like a
comedy brother like group like like the
Wayne's Brothers like they're all close
they're all super nice they're all
actors yeah and then they're like they
have hella family so all like everyone
comes through and I'm just like man I'm
so envious of that like not only family
and camaraderie but support you guys
have for each other it's really sick he
has he has Legacy status for sure yeah
are they Jehovah's
Witness I hope so that's hot is it I
don't know we should have been Jehovah's
huh I feel like when families come up
they're usually like Jehovah's Witnesses
or [__] Morman oh Mormon yeah yeah I do
enjoy his Tik toks where he does the
residual checks oh yeah when they're
just like pennies and [__] yeah he just
like he gets his mail he's like residual
check and he just opens to reveal like
how much he got paid for some random
project that he did whatever pretty fun
like if I met that many
celebs oh we met a lot we just never got
close did you meet want to make a good
impression like our favorite one right
that's the prompt like did you meet
Michelle yo on brother son yeah but we
didn't do anything what do you mean I
mean I
mean I was just
inside no I was just I was just inside
she walked in everybody was like you
know what I mean like [__] it's she a
legend and she would sit down and like
glasses down and she'd be like so what
are we going on today I was like oh [__]
I don't even want to do I just watched
police story with like taica oh she fine
in police god well her ability is insane
her ability is [__] doing [__]
splits on trains and back flips off cars
and [__] I was like holy [__] dude
Tomorrow Never Dies she's hot in there
too yeah she's incredible she's fine
she's a blond girl she's insane cool to
see her real life though did you do the
splits just for no reason I don't know
saw where's the
craft she was in our previous she just
walked into our stage and we like I was
like what department always has to be
like wow no you know you just keep
working you got you know keep it to
yourself do thing with everybody else
that was it I bet you if you're next to
vanam he'd do the splits oh yeah if you
he probably insist on if you gave him
like a 20 $20 bill he'd do the splits
for oh yeah he need money I heard like
Nicholas Cage oh well Nicholas Cage does
a hella more directed DVD [__] though so
he's getting paid but he's a lot of
overhead he has like too many castles
and [__] like that I like his recent
movie dude the one where he played
himself that was really good good wow
watch with Pedro Pas yeah mhm so what
about a celebrity you did meet though
cuz that's the prompt you met and left a
good impression yeah good impression I
don't know if I left any good impression
really they all suck at you left a good
impression they left a good impression
on somebody you met that you like what's
that tall dude you know what's that tall
dude um he does hosting all the time
Ryan SEC Chris oh Conan O'Brien con
O'Brien cool
he's tall he's [__] hell hell tall
yeah he's like wow I think he's like 65
or some [__] where Jimmy coner uh I was
doing I was doing uh what do you call
the Clippers uh you know where you guys
run around throw t-shirts those useless
piece of dudes you know what I mean just
go around just go around and [__]
throw t-shirts forgot did you even get
did you get to use the cannon I did I
did that [__] was sick but a harder you
shove it down farther it goes just just
FY trade bro good to know but uh I was
in backstage I was packing up the
clothes and you just see him walking
hella tall and I was just like yo isn't
that freaking uh yo you know what I mean
that yo can I take a picture with you
and he lit without hesitation instantly
turns around like yeah of course oh
that's such a he just like you're Korean
aren't you and I was like what how you
how do you know did he say did he say
you got a [__] face is that was that what
he says David always says that David
Goes K's got a [__] face and I'm like I
don't know popular question what it is
yeah but he instantly knew I was Korean
and he started speaking to me in
Korean that's all he said though that's
pretty it was good impression what a
great interaction really cool he would
be that cool though yeah that's cool man
that's why I took a picture he's not
that tall saw real life cuz I'm really
tall
too just saw On My Level
really nobody B I'm trying to think the
first time I ever met a a
celebrity a real one like a real one I
remember it was Wesley Snipes oh that
was a real one that's true but on that
day it was Wesley Snipes Don Cheeto it
Don Cheeto was there it wasn't Don
Cheeto I think it was Michael J white
was
there oh Michael J white I was like oh
[__] this guy's way bigger than I
thought than I thought he was are you
sure Don Cheeto wasn't there Don I don't
think Don Cheeto and arold know each
other all right so yeah it was uh yeah
Wesley Snipes that was pretty cool to
see him cracking jokes with his mom and
his dad cuz uh we had a friend Nam
Arnold Chan he's like a legend in the
stunt game Oh Hell and him and Wesley
Snipes are like best friends growing up
we were sitting next to him watching a a
fight yeah but I couldn't focus on the
fight UFC fight or something sitting
there and he's just cracking jokes just
like a regular ass dude with his parents
and then um yeah I saw Michael J white
there then I saw um [__] what's the
other guy's name he's in a bunch of
movies Don Cheeto it's Dono I guarantee
we Don Cheeto was there [__] he's in all
kinds of movies what's the uh have you
guys watched that movie I think it's
called the big hit yeah with uh Blue
Diamond Phillips yeah and Mark Wahlberg
and who's the other guy the black dude
in that film Don
Cheeto or something what the [__] his
name baby Keem no dude it's not Don
Cheeto or oh I know who you're talking
about walking Phoenix no no no no no no
you it was Don cheet I think that's what
I think oh boim Woodbine oh he's cool
yeah yeah he's [__]
awesome ohes that look like Dave
Chappelle like above Dave Chappelle yeah
wait da yo I thought that was Dave
Chappelle that's crazy so that was
pretty cool if I didn't really interact
with too many of them that's insane
today's video is brought to you by
DraftKings looking for a super offer for
Super Bowl 58 DraftKings Sportsbook has
you cover new customers can bet on the
big game and turn five bucks into 200
instantly in bonus bets check out these
lines and odds and see where you want to
place your bets download the draftking
sports book app now and use the code off
the Record new customers can bet five
bucks and get 200 instantly in bonus
bets only on draft King sports book an
official sports betting partner of Super
Bowl 58 with code off the Record the
crown is yours gambling problem call
1800 Gambler or in West Virginia visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net in New York call
8778 hope NY or text h o p n46 7369 in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 888 78977 777 or
visit ccpg dorg please play responsibly
on behalf of Boothill Casino and Resort
in Kansas 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario bonus bets
expire 168 hours after issuance see
dk.com for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming resources but you know what's
cool I was a star struck like [__] every
single every single commercial break our
friend would grab different celebrities
to go upstairs to his little computer it
literally felt like you're in a high
school like birthday party where he
would just grab them force them to go up
and watch our JK
videos that's cool as [__] no I wanted
to leave we were so embarrassed Don
Cheeto saw you guys' video that's sick
all of them did Terence Howard
did Patriot the war machine war machine
the war machine dude no uh yeah we're
just downstairs and we didn't even go up
with him he just kept grabbing oh you
got to go check him out and I was like
oh please don't I just I don't want to
get kicked out of this house I like be
in this house did you tell them you
watch Hotel Rwanda no well they came
downstairs laughing but I'm like that's
a good sign was that to be nice I guess
so it didn't make us famous it did it
was worthless no that's pain that's true
pain that's real pain it's actual pain
and then I I remember meeting Barry
Bonds uh when I was running on a track I
just shook his hand and I was like holy
[__] your hand's humongous so I don't
know if that's a good impression or not
and then oh I got James Franco's
autograph cuz he was going to UCL at the
same time cool so I saw him and I like
oh [__] I you're the guy from Spider-Man
I'm like hey can I get your autograph
he's like sure and he scribed some stuff
and then me and Gio got together we
moved in together she like hey you know
that binder you had like I I threw away
that paper I was like God someone's
autograph oh [__] it and then um oh [__]
it I threw away that one paper I don't
know if I like had an actual interaction
where I was like Bobby Lee we grew up
watching him on Matt TV but I don't know
if it's a positive impression you
know that's true yeah Bobby doesn't
really come around here anymore yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't know if I
had any like one where I was like oh
that guy's like like you know those
stories where like like you're a server
and they tip 200% and you're like w
you're looking for those ones any like
they're just like regular not bad not
good for me yeah not bad or good just
volcano yeah yeah he was he they T they
tipped like way more than what they ate
it was him Kevin James Rob Schneider and
a lady crazy and um while you were
working at volcano yeah and then um they
had to do the whole stanions and the
ropes around it because people were
trying to bug and then they're just like
come on like let them eat whatever and
then like sick they are really nice
though cuz when they finished eating
they literally went up to every single
person and then they went to every
single staff and then like shook hands
took pictures said Thank you and then
they left did anybody on the staff have
to do that smart ass thing with like oh
hey I used to watch your stuff yeah nah
God but that happens a lot to people we
know us to yeah oh you know who did
something really cool that they didn't
have to at all simu actually really so
when he got booked for Shane Chi
afterwards you know they do like their
whole like PR press conference [__] so
he's like in men's health whatever all
these things he got booked for a shoot
for men's health and then they go oh do
you have a trainer and I don't think he
really has a trainer I think he's just
one of those guys that just genetically
just pretty lean and he hit me up he
goes hey would you be down to be my
trainer in the magazine and then later
we'll plug your gym and I was like oh
[__] I'm like yeah I'm down so I end up
being his trainer and then off camera
like he would come up to me like like oh
what what should I do and I'm just tell
him I'm just get these bands and just
pull them like this and then you would
see all the makeup people oh see this is
how a superhero gets trained and in my
brain I'm like that is not how a superer
get but we just kind of put on this
whole show to get him like a little pump
and he's taking these pictures and later
on men's health did a whole feature at
ble Brigade like this is where Shane Chi
trained and then so like that's [__]
SI was like lifting and doing stuff so
like he didn't have to do any of that it
was just I think him like pushing like
Asian Americans forward in in uh you on
yeah and then like bringing on other
people that he goes oh you know who else
should be like brought on and stuff and
I'm like that's I don't he he doesn't
owe me anything and and he did that that
I thought that was pretty cool it's such
a stupid [__] J akk thing that you
can't just sit here and say that you're
his trainer you have to tell everybody
behind the scenes it's a
fugazi it would really help everything
if you're just like yeah I trained him
for the movie we're so not playing the
game so stupid I love this place though
that's why we're never [__] Hollywood
can't play any game yeah it's the news
though cuz those stories are better and
because he's a [__] Disney asset it's
an undisclosed location and I was like
oh [__] I got to get dumbbells and bands
up to this place and I don't even know
which building in Downtown I am as I'm
texting adem I'm like I think it's on
Third and he would like I'm like going
through Alleyways and [__] and he has
trying to like find out where the [__] I
am and then we bring dumbbells and bands
upstairs and N like oh sh you're
training them like no I'm not training
them what's at all we just need to get
these things to pretend like it looks
like we're training them but it was cool
yeah I had a similar cool experience
with C too because same thing he he just
like I didn't know that he was a dancer
on on a college team in his college back
in Canada so he had like watched like
Kindra [__] too so when we were like
going to collab and stuff he came
through and he was telling us these
stories how he used to watch some of our
videos and whatnot so being able to
actually just like collab with him was
super just chill but still just just
being like all the people in the studio
like the the dance studio or like even
like Nina's sisters and stuff would hit
us up afterwards and be like yo are you
a see you know what I mean it was just
such a [__] crazy like EOS system
rocking for people and just being like
yo that was so fortunate for us to be
able to just like be in that space with
him cuz he like likes dance too you know
he's like I used to have sleep at me and
I started watching kja
videos what's your story Steve which
one so oh no you honestly Missy pile is
like the coolest Missy pile she's in
like a shitload of stuff if you look at
her up you'd be like holy [__] can't
believe this worked with Missy pile um
yeah Missy pile for sure Missy pile um
oh Keith David Keith David is the
[__]
Mane didn't you write what his no I
didn't I didn't no he was in a movie my
buddy did called Smiley I was also in
that movie but I didn't write anything
but um but Kei David like he was from
they live remember that scene where
they're fighting each other in the
alleyway like he's he's one of the guys
in that with Ry R Piper and uh he is so
[__] cool like I remember one day we
were like working on promoting um the
movie just like bullshitting things for
it and we had him it was just me him my
buddy Mike gager in the studio and he
was like cuning he was like doing like a
a [__] like old Sinatra song and I
was like what the hell is happening this
is hilarious to me his voice is magical
it is no he is great but it was just
hilarious how I mean nothing that he was
doing was funny it was just hilarious
like I can't believe I'm in a room with
Keith David so yeah and he's really cool
super awesome guy um yeah oh you know
who's [__] we know that's that's a
celebrity cool as [__] Sun
Kang was really so I would love to meet
I want to meet him like we got to
actually film with them he [__] took
us out to this Chinese ass restaurant
what we were just talking for hours and
then like and then he he had a a movie
with Stallone and then we went to his
movie premiere and he was telling us
like Stallone came out in like platform
shoes cuz he's actually's a tall dude
and then so when they're ready to shoot
he came out in platform shoes and he was
like what you think I'm going to let you
be short the taller than me and then
he's all like all right [__] it you Sun
King also made me do some of the most
embarrassing things I've ever done in my
life too this was during the time where
like where like YouTube uh was getting
like you know those those vertical
channels where like YouTube would be
like okay here's like a million dollar
for you guys you guys will develop this
here's a million dollar during that boom
yeah so he was part of uh the yam yam F
crew and whatever video I it's it's it's
up this video doesn't even make sense
but for some reason I think think uh he
put me in these short shorts and like a
gold chain and rubbed the baby oil all
over me this already sounds like a
regular Bart video yeah and then I'm
like doing something with some Japanese
lady and I don't even know what's going
on that sounds hot but it was a full
shoot day still like 12 hours where like
you're liberal or something that what it
is is it is it a music video I don't
even know I think well it was because oh
my son King you're you're weird man that
makeup artist I think the inside joke
was like that makeup artist was like
their friend and then she's like boy
crazy or something and then so you were
like the guy she was thirsting over okay
I just didn't know those ideas lived in
his mind sounds kind of tight you know
who else is dope sounds Hollywood
remember the movie Friday pops yeah oh
John Withers SP man he was the man dude
he was the man don't tell nobody yeah
so such a funny guy I got to do like a
little scene with him for video for
YouTube video years ago and he's just so
cool so generous so like nice and like
such a giving scene partner and stuff
like that and then yeah I've known his
son over the years and so it was like a
bummer like going to his funeral cuz I
was like damn he's the guy was such a
lively like character every time you're
around him he's like exactly that guy
that you see in the movies wow and then
yeah seeing him like not not that that
is [__] it was wild he's great you know
was [__] cool too Bobby H hundreds is
actually really oh yeah he's super duper
cool cuz like his um like his network is
insane
and like he invited me to one of his
dinners and like everyone there's like
someone and like I was sitting right
next to Mark Hoppus from blink 1882 and
we're just all eating whatever and then
he likes to like you know like have
everyone gel so he's just going around
the room lot you guys probably know him
he couple albums blink to whatever and
then he goes to oh it's Mike shoda
Lincoln Park and this whatever whatever
and he gets like me and Gio and he was
like oh dude these guys are like the
king and queen of YouTube like what the
[__] shut the [__] up you have to lie
about this [__] but it was just crazy
like the the way he elevates it and then
he sets up the room so sick that he goes
like like everyone has like a 5 minute
hype story and then he leaves and it's
just like Network yeah yeah like he's
just so [__] cool like that I'm like
dude that's [__] insane damn he just
creates such a good vibe in community so
everyone's like like defenses are down
no one feels like oh dude are you trying
to like leech off me or anything he just
creates such a dope environment and
everyone is just like now Buds and stuff
it's like pre vetting everyone to each
other yeah yeah I loved meeting him too
bad you didn't get to meet him he's
really cool yeah he had a lot of great
uh jokes is that is that where you met
donel uh yes I swear to God Don Cheeto
was there he was there
[__] it's so easy to set it off
I'm going [__] ask Arnold right now
I'm like this is so Random you if he
says yes we have to do a whole video
about how how Joe actually met Don
Cheeto even though he doesn't I seen him
but what did you say to him what you
seen him no he was there watching I
didn't I didn't say hi to anybody I was
scared I wanted to act cool like I'm
Hollywood too you know who's who's
actually pretty cool is uh Big Sean yeah
yeah he was really nice there's a video
with him uh it's the song's called uh
the song's called skateboard p and it's
Big Sean and uh made in
tyo and then um do you know that song
skateboard P tyo Maybe by sound I don't
know yeah there's a so in the music
video I randomly ended up there because
back when I had my DeLorean rented out
for shoots and then this production
company rented it for this shoot I
didn't even know it was them when I got
there and then um there's a in that
video there's a part where him and the
other artists are sitting on the hood of
my car and they're just rapping and the
car's like slowly going forward I'm in
there trying to drive it like this and
not be seen like the ghost riding the
whip yeah yeah yeah cuz it's supposed to
look like it's going by itself but it's
actually me going like this oh [__] and
like every after every take he's like
hey sorry man like and he would always
uh check after sitting he would check if
it got scratched and I'm like you're too
rich to [__] give a [__] about that
and he would always be like oh sorry man
sorry like sorry for having to sit on it
and everything like nobody's ever cared
about that like regular people don't
care about that that's why they're
regular damn I also met Robin Williams
real quick every so quickly met Rin
Williams lucky it was very quick though
but it was like cool to meet him but
then it was sad because the next day he
was coming to ucv to like come watch a
show or whatever
and then um the next day I see like Rob
Williams is back in rehab so like he was
like he had relapse that night cuz they
saw you to UC heard a joke from you
saying no no I was I was actually we
were we were collaborating they saw you
we were collaborating that night I was
selling him a ticket they're like who is
this guy oh I need a
drink I didn't I didn't get to do a bit
I didn't get to do a joke how do I
forget that
show he kill himself he's like that guy
who sold me the ticket his is so ugly I
had to start drinking the guy staring at
his ex across the bar that impr show was
so bad good recall
M wait what was your rehabing
for you mean who I
think his elbow yeah yeah yeah yeah
probably KNE yeah he to go to I didn't
know he had a drug problem yeah I didn't
know that's why that's why I was like
[Music]
what